What else, besides the glutathione, will keep the cancer cells alive at a good shape that we should stay away from?
Well, you should stay away from antioxidants if you have cancer.
Now, there's argument that, okay, my cancer is not active.
I've been full remission. I've been in full remission now for three years.
Should I start taking antioxidants?
Well, you could argue that. You know that, okay, well, you're in full remission.
No, let's try to make sure you don't get cancer elsewhere.
So, I'm not against, it's just because a person has had cancer at one point in time doesn't mean they could never take antioxidants again.
No, but when you have active cancer and it is active and you don't have it in full remission, or you just maybe are calling it a ton and everything to go on antioxidants is not a good idea.
So, it would be any antioxidants glutathione is just the primary and most active intracellular antioxidant.
So, no, there's some nutrients that act like antioxidants that can be good for certain cancers though.
So, it's not just a clear cut thing, but it's like lung cancer is a little bit different where certain things that act as antioxidants elsewhere actually help with lung cancer.
So, it's not perfectly clear cut. Glutathione though, that's just across the board, no matter what cancer.
Because that is the primary intracellular antioxidant.
So, again, like that person who said my IV therapist wants to put me an IV glutathione, it just does not make any sense whatsoever to me.
I don't know why, they're not looking at the data there.